[Music]
my glamour I'm Nick and I am my cast of
glamour Woman of the Year for YouTube
2017 thank you very very much and today
I'm here to show you how you can get
red-carpet ready
firstly we will make sure my skin is
well moisturized I have got a Charlotte
Tilbury magic cream normally just work
as my skin you do not have to use a
brush I'm just using a brush since I'm
going to use it for the next three steps
anyway then I'm going to take a little
bit of radiance activator this one is by
estate edit and the top a bit on the
back of my hand this is my go-to primer
and radiance cream because it just gives
a lovely glow to the skin then in with a
little bit of creme de Mer lip balm just
onto my lips so that when I come to put
my lipstick on there really well
nourished I think that's quite an
important step I'm going to leave that
to really work into the skin and move on
to eyes I'm going to take a little bit
of nods can see that this one is in the
color custard and I fit really dark in
here so I'm going to run that just in
here and then take a nice domed brush
just going to buff that into the inner
corner she's great for those people that
get a very deep socket I don't want to
put some eye shadow on to the eye but
I'm gonna start with a Korean one this
one is FA a bit again actually and it is
called Oh a meteor shower I'm going to
make another deluxe crease brush and
just buff that over the lid and put a
tip that up and under here you have like
a little pigment I'm going to take some
of that with the same brush we're going
to use a different brush so the top so
as a lovely light shimmer take a bit of
getting used to not having your
foundation on already
cuz you feel like oh this just looks
really crazy but you'll get used to it
and actually in the long run it's worth
it because your makeup won't fall down
it will look nicer for longer and then I
want to take a little bit of brown
eyeliner this one is Charlotte Tilbury
and the classic powder eye pencil it's
in a really really dark rich brown going
on a tiny
here tiny bit here tiny ripped summer
top waterline take my breath I used for
the eyeshadow chest Buster in it's such
a soft pencil which is why I like it but
it just disappears after just a few
strokes it's busting and blended makes
life very easy mascara I have got YSL
volume effect mascara in the wild a
decor it's my favorite then I'm going to
move back from the foundation I have got
Mac face and body make sure you shake it
well I tend to use two colors and mix
them both together
this is n2 and c7 and I put it on my
body as well especially on my legs if my
legs are going to be out and mix it with
a bit of moisturizer and I tend to go on
the legs a little bit more of the darker
color with a touch of the lighter one
and on the rest of my skin are you
probably a touch more of a lighter one
with a darker one just want my legs to
be a bit Brown
so a little bit of enter with a dab of
c7 start from the nose and pull outwards
and then one of the important things is
that this doesn't have an SPF in this
foundation so it photographs beautifully
you'll find that if something had an SPF
in it flashes back so the SPF is what
the flicks and repels the Sun it's going
to do exactly the same to a flash on the
camera back in with my concealer my
faithful knives under the eyes down the
nose around here and just take the same
brush they used the concealer earlier
just to buff that in see how much of a
difference it makes to do the eyes first
because the foundation just looks so
fresh and healthy right another great
little trick keep your concealer brush
in your hand take the one you use for
the eye shadow but the eye shadows out
with the eye shadow one and then if you
feel like it happens when ended
perfectly take your 1/4 concealer and
just run it over the top and it just
acts like an eraser and just
hiding it up for you some does all the
hard work there I want to shape my face
a tiny bit I have got this - you're
blushing contour I'm going to take the
contour and just run it downtown be sure
take it around the hairline a little bit
I'm mature but if you feel you need it
then brush it before I use the
foundation and just bust a.m. by using
all the other products with the brush
first just allowing it to have a lot
more slip and makes it easier for me to
use and by running the bronzer through
the hairline makes it more natural it
makes me look look I've got a bit of a
tan because I've already said I like to
you the darker color on my legs when I
put foundation on them before our powder
I tend to go in with a bit of bronzer I
have got this hoola bronzer from benefit
and a new Real Techniques brush is the
powder brush and I'm going to take the
who laughs and it will cling to where my
skin has a shine which I want going to
give me a love really tiny finish then
for my favorite pal that this is the
Charlotte Tilbury powder airbrush
flawless finished it's beautiful and
I've got another real technique powder
blue brush I'm just gonna I like the
fact that the brush is small it's really
important you can work the powder where
you need the powder so under the eyes a
little bit here I don't want to get too
much flash there on the cheer me chin
chin now on the other end of minder your
stick is a highlighter I'm going to
actually take it off of the stick and
use it with my fingers but the stick
might drag it a bit so I just want to
tap it on with my fingers tiny bit of
that around here
a little bit of pixie cream blush again
with my fingers to add a little bit of a
rosy glow can then go add a tiny bit of
Estee Lauder
brow multitasker just through the brows
red carpet makeup is just meant to make
you look like a better version of
yourself not like someone else
completely
so don't go to everywhere
the other lipstick I've got this
Victoria Beckham nude spice map this is
max brush glass earrings big baby and
then you have my finished red carpet
makeup thank you so much for watching
and glamour and keep so much a phenomena
ting asked for YouTube Woman of the Year
take care of you